Speaker 1: So there was a Senate hearing yesterday
involving a number of different public health
officials, the new CDC director, Rochelle
Walensky, participated, and so did Dr. Anthony
Fauci, the top infectious disease doctor in
the United States.
And Republican Senator Rand Paul was there.
Rand Paul has been increasingly fixated on
a covid lab leak conspiracy.
And this all came to a spectacular head yesterday
when Rand Paul, I guess, confronted Dr. Fauci
about it.
And Dr. Fauci reacted by saying quite plainly,
Rand Paul has no idea what the hell he's talking
about and we're going to pick it up near the
start and dove into it.
Let's go right into the first clip.
Speaker 4: Think about that for a moment.
The SARS virus had a 15 percent mortality.
We're fighting a pandemic that has about a
one percent mortality.
Can you imagine if a SARS virus that's been
juiced up and had viral proteins added to
it to the spike protein if that were released
accidentally?
Dr. Fauci, do you still support funding of
the NIH funding of the lab and move on?
Senator Paul, with all due respect, you are
entirely, entirely and completely incorrect
that the NIH has not ever and does not now
fund gain of function research in the Wuhan
Institute.
Do they feel like we do not fund Barrack's
gain of function research?
Dr. Barrett does not doing gain of function
research.
And if it is, it's according to the guidelines
and it is being conducted in North Carolina.
Not only thing concerning a bad virus, spike
protein.
Speaker 1: OK, so let's break down some of
this stuff.
It is certainly possible that this one lab
was researching coronaviruses and even could
have been researching this specific coronavirus
strain in their lab.
And that should be looked at because it might
have leaked in addition to it already having
been out in the world as an accident, that's
certainly possible.
It should be investigated what some people
are going to.
Is that this was a bioengineered weapon amplified
at the Wuhan lab and released into the public,
there is no evidence of that whatsoever.
Now, with all of these conspiracies, one and
one can always say in conspiracists typically
do.
You've not definitively proven that that hasn't
happened.
But when you make the extraordinary claim
or when you make a claim for which we have
not seen evidence, then you should at least
look for or present some evidence if you want
to be taken seriously.
So this is like layer one of the conspiracy,
which is establishing, as Rand Paul is trying
to do, that the NIH and Dr. Fauci himself
in some cases were specifically funding research
at the Wuhan lab.
But Dr. Fauci says we did not fund what is
called the gain of function research.
If you don't know what that term means, it's
going to be hard to follow the rest of this
conversation.
Gain of function research is research into
making a microorganism, a virus, et cetera,
have increased transmissibility, increased
virulence, increased immunogenicity from what
it has through a variety of different processes,
processes that can be done in a lab.
And Dr. Fauci simply says that wasn't being
done and we're not funding that.
And Dr. Fauci was ready for what followed
from Rand Paul here that
Speaker 4: he got from the Wuhan Institute
into the SARS virus gain of function.
That is not a minority because at least 200
scientists have signed a statement from the
Cambridge Working Group saying that it is
going to function well.
It is not.
And if you look at the grant and you look
at the progress reports, it is not going to
function despite the fact that people tweet
that so support sending money to the Human
Virology Institute.
We do not send money now to do going on and
sending money.
We did under your tutelage.
We were sending it through AECO Health.
It was a subagency and a sub grant.
Do you support that?
The money from NIH that was going to that
we want institute.
Let me explain to you why that was done.
The sors covid one originated in bats in China.
It would have been irresponsible of us if
we did not investigate the bat viruses and
the serology to see who might have been perhaps
in China as well to send it to the Chinese.
Speaker 1: So Dr Foushee was totally ready
for that.
And Rand Paul had to then scale back the question
you might have noticed.
OK, OK, OK.
It wasn't that type of research, but in this
particular case.
But do you support sending any money to the
Wuhan Institute of Virology?
And Fauci says we do not.
And Rand Paul says, well, OK, yep, we did.
And maybe well, the situation was related
to SARS covid one.
And of course, we would fund research where
it originated.
That's an important thing to understand.
We were we were looking at sars-cov-2 one
and we were looking at it where it originated.
It makes sense to do that.
Why wouldn't we be doing that?
OK, so then they move on.
But Rand Paul keeps pushing at Dr. Fauci stuff.
That is simply not true and false.
He just keeps beating it off.
Rand Paul goes back again to gain of function
research and Foushee again has to beat it,
beat it back.
Speaker 4: Absolutely.
Shinies vote to send it to the Chinese government
that we may not be able to trust with this
knowledge and with this incredibly dangerous
viruses, government scientists like yourself
who favor gain of function, I don't favor
gain information, research Chinese and claim
that are not correct government defenders
of gain of function such as yourself.
Speaker 1: Rand Paul just won't be deterred.
Right.
And this is not it.
Rand Paul keeps going.
It starts to get painful.
Look at this.
Speaker 4: In the U.S., we have eleven labs
doing it and you have allowed it here.
We have a committee to do it.
But the committee has granted every exemption.
You're you're fooling with Mother Nature here.
You're allowing super viruses to be created
with a 15 percent mortality.
It's very dangerous.
And it was a huge mistake to share this with
China.
And it's a huge mistake to allow this to continue
in the United States.
We should be very careful to investigate where
this virus came from.
I fully agree that you should investigate
where the virus came from.
But again, we have not funded gain of function
research on this virus in the U.S. Institute
of Virology.
No matter passing on your part, say there
was research, there was research done with
Dr. Shi and Dr. Bearak.
They have collaborated on a gain of function
research where they enhance the SARS virus
to infect human airway cells.
And they did it by merging a new spike protein
on it.
That is gain of function that was joint.
Research between the Human Institute and Dr.
Parikh, you can't deny Senator Paul
Speaker 2: your time has expired.
Dr. Crouch, I will let you respond to that.
We need to move on.
Speaker 4: Excuse me.
I will allow you to respond to that and then
we'll move on.
Yeah, I mean, I just wanted to say, I don't
know how many times I can say it.
Madam Chair, we did not fund gain of function
research to be conducted in the U.S. Institute
of Virology.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
You almost don't really need Dr. Fauci there.
And this is a typical sometimes the term grandstanding
is thrown around for what happens in these
Senate hearings.
And one way that I identify grandstanding
is that even without the the guest or the
witness or the person giving testimony, you
almost don't need them for the senator to
just keep doing what they're what they do
and saying what they say.
They are going to say their piece, regardless
of what the witness contributes.
And Rand Paul is just reading this stuff,
regardless of what Dr. Fauci says.
And then lastly, and this is really important
because of what it points to, Senator Tinsmith,
who's a Democrat from Minnesota, points out
that line of questioning from Rand Paul.
When Rand Paul does that, it increases vaccine
hesitancy.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: Thank you, Chair Murray, and thank
you so much to our panelists for being here
today.
I want to just following up on that exchange.
I just asked Dr. Fauci a question.
Dr. Fauci, what is the impact of conspiracy
theories peddled by Senator Rand Paul and
others on Americans willingness to take this
vaccine, a vaccine that, by all accounts,
is remarkable for its safety and efficacy?
Speaker 4: Well, conspiracy theories certainly
are not helpful in what we're trying to do,
I guess I can say that with some degree of
confidence.
Speaker 2: Well, I would agree, and I
Speaker 1: think and that's exactly right,
Dr. Fouche is being extremely careful and
reserved in his language.
I get that.
But this is a major problem when you start
to see these lines of questioning, particularly
from senators like Rand Paul who have such
wacky bases, bases of support.
Can we trust anything?
Can we trust what science knows about the
origins of the virus?
Can we trust what anybody tells us about vaccines
or the seriousness of the disease, about the
need to get vaccinated, about anything?
And Dr. Fauci, just doing everything he can
to try to resist these continued propaganda
efforts from people like Rand Paul.
And it is not merely an annoyance, because
you and I know that if he were not dealing
with this and if he had not been dealing with
this stuff for the last year, plus Dr. Fauci
could have done so much more by focusing his
energy elsewhere.
But you have to fight this stuff off.
It's also that it gets this these narratives
into people's minds and then they don't get
vaccinated or they don't wear masks where
they should or whatever the case may be.
So there's a real world impact here for Rand
Paul.
Maybe it is performative theater.
I don't know.
I don't really know what's in Rand Paul, Rand
Paul's head, but it has a destructive real
world impact.